[Musik]
gst
diese waren aber jetzt mal rede sind sie
einmal am bildschirm 20
[Musik]
unglaublich die aggerenergie und um die
begreift reger und intensität die hand
dran glaubt aber auch heute glaubt ort
revolution
wir sind überzeugt dass wird revolution
erfahren und zwar noch morgen oder
übermorgen sondern jetzt sofort und das
ist genau darum bis zum sieg mit jobs so
unglaublich klein mache brücke
präsidentin vor organisation collet war
genau das grobe bacher genau seitlich
sache wecken
aber dafür muss ich vielleicht warte ja
dass jetzt alles hinter mir werden die
zahl der bio aber weißt du bist jetzt
die 28 jährige tamara von cello und die
74 jährige andré valentin kämpfen beide
für die rechte der frauen
andré valentin seit 1968 was audi
aktionen dir dir was da alles was da für
ein energie freigesetzt wurden mehr
möchte versuchen frauen die frauen zum
bewusstsein bringen dass sie inneren
unterdrückte stelle klatten wenig außer
der familie in einer multikulturellen
familie schon mal mein vater ist
franzose mini mutter tessinerin die
ansicht hoffen im kampf und mein vater
es musik praktisch solo oboisten im ton
einer nachricht ob sie das hand in
zürich lebt und da bin ich oft ihre
vierte 50er jahre
aber die sache ist ein trister nordsee
ja ein ort wo sehr konservativ und ii an
und dann ist das viel
und sie dankt merkt an dass man die
mutter sofort zwischen mir und meiner
schwester lourdes künstler sind ja zu
einfach
und dass sie eigentlich nicht wirklich
auf ihre kosten und mit all dem musiker
hat ihre unfähigkeit das bedeutet sie es
musste auch besonders gehen als nur das
und ich bin auch sehr lebendig sehen und
sehe immer sehr neugierig sie und vor
fange ich mir eigentlich quatsch ich bin
ich gut weil darüber aber nicht
sabine verschiedensten dimensionen
erleben und nicht nur als ehefrau und
aber auch aktiv an der gesellschaft
einen beitrag leisten der marathonis
cello leistet ihren beitrag als
präsidentin der jungsozialisten der
schweiz für ihr studium hat sie im
moment keine zeit als
vollblutpolitikerin geht ihre ganze
energie in den kampf für eine gerechtere
welt
feminismus ist für mich die
emanzipatorische bewegung von
machtstrukturen also dazu zwingt mit
frechen zu erhalten
sie wächst mit ihrem jüngeren bruder in
einem linken haushalt auf den großteil
ihrer kindheit verbringen sie auf
sardinien der heimat ihres vaters ein
freies leben mit viel zeit zum spielen
und lesen sie mac & tina ist einfach
klar ist die einzige fing sie unter dem
schutz der gut sein oder gar nicht aber
ich glaube nicht an diesen fünf minuten
registriert haben dazu sagen wird dass
bei etwa irgendwie so geben können ihre
eltern sind stark in sozialen bewegungen
engagiert
und diskutieren sehr viel mit ihren
kindern grund bei uns gesehen mit ja mit
beruhigend sich von daheim als die junge
und die valentin erreicht was sie will
sie studiert zuerst wirtschaft und dann
geschichte und soziologie
aber vor dem abschluss kommt ihr das
leben dazwischen den vielen sachen april
mai 68 tochter sagte weko ich ja und das
hat alles über der hufe geriet
unter dem pflaster liegt der strand also
suchen oder strand das ist wichtig da
haben es hannes studium abbrechen
nachdem ist so wahnsinnig viele
verschiedene schritt gemacht haben und
in dem kontinent so kann ich dann mit
ganz total politische weg bewegung
widmet ja im historischen museum in bern
begegnen die beiden frauen sich zum
ersten mal in einer ausstellung über den
aufbruch von 1968 oder statik sowie sie
herr grüne sie der rbc raffinierter 18
jahren die farben audi gedeckten tisch
nur interessant
willkommen in der spielhölle
in der gesellschaft der 60er jahre haben
alle ihren platz plötzlich training
also generation herr unterschied zu dem
sich riesig dass ich mir vorstelle die
50er 60er jahre wie konform gesellschaft
ist wie frau gymnasium gemacht
berichtete kurzausbildung mehr geortet
aber den und den schaffen und den halt
machen und so gut sein wie das ist alles
sehr genau volk sexy sehr vorbestimmt
und 1968 ist sex vor der ehe ein tabu
paare dürfen nur verheiratet zusammen
leben
es gilt ein kombinats verbot abtreibung
ist strafbar
wollen frauen einem beruf nachgehen
müssen sie die ehemänner um erlaubnis
bitten
und sie haben politisch keine stimme
die schweizer frauen teilen vor
wahllokalen das schicksal mitteln hunden
dieser zustand wird bei weitem nicht von
allen aber von vielen schweizerinnen als
entwürdigend empfunden und was sagen die
deutschschweizer männer die im schatten
des bundeshauses zu bären ihren
geschäften nachgehen
dafür fahren was halten sie vom
frauenstimmrecht
ich bin dagegen warum die frau gehört
ins haus sie soll muttersein und fertig
die frauen haben ein anderes zu tun dass
haushalt bis abends hinter schauen dass
glaube es ist besser wenn es nicht so
weit kommt das pech ihrer politischen
niederlagen verbrennen die
schweizerinnen an alljährlichen
fackelzügen es ist ein schweigemarsch
fürs mitreden dürfen
und vielleicht werden die männer
irgendwann von der großzügigen einzig
heimgesucht dass sie lange genug allein
gefackelt hat der harz daneben der
frauen vertrauen und die hand dann in
dem schauspielhaus hans dann die 50 jahr
jubiläum feiert und daher mehr frauen in
aktion gemacht
andré valentin ist präsidentin der
fortschrittlichen studenten zürich fsz
in dieser funktion sturm 10 mit anderen
frauen die bühne und ergreift das
mikrofon
[Applaus]
wir fragen uns wo zu dieser feier mit
musik und bankett wissen wir nicht dass
das jubilieren im blick auf unsere
wirkliche situation verdeckt wir sollten
nicht jubilieren sondern protestieren
und diskutieren
[Applaus]
machen wir einen anfang lassen wir die
obligate musik beiseite die diskussion
ist eröffnet
wie ich reagiert das kann ich das
absolute skandal zieht wieder auf der
bühne am mikrofon die an sich gar nicht
verstanden was los ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dass ich nun klopfen nicht
meine damen ich weiß das nicht wenn man
diskussionen würden wir uns mit der
polizei gedroht was ist denn das was
sind das für zu stellen ist das nicht
berechtigt dafür miteinander diskutieren
wenn wir schon einmal zusammen sitzen
und dann hat's auch sdxc und dann
herausstellte bieter gang und am schluss
bin ich wiederum bühne unter hammer
anfangen diskutiere und systemisch dann
frauen beträgt bewegen standen sofort
das heißt nicht dass ich dann hattest
entwickelt das ist gründungs jedes nur
begründen die nummer ja genau
er empfinde das stimmrecht okay das ist
eine grundbedingung us-mannschaft für
jedermann stimmrecht und das hat monika
und aber als sie forderungen sind
natürlich viel viel weiter gegangen als
nur frauenstimmrecht steht es mit der
ausbildung der frauen während jeder
waren heranwachsende man eine ernährungs
ausbildung genießt bleiben zwei trägt
oder frauen um gelernt wie steht es mit
den himmel schreienden ungerechtigkeiten
in dem in der entlöhnung gleichwertige
arbeit
[Applaus]
wie steht es mit einer zivilrechtlichen
gleichstellung im vermögens und er recht
wahrscheinlich kennen viele nicht einmal
die verstaubten paragrafen die da sagen
dass die frau um einen beruf auszuüben
da genehmigung des ehemannes bedarf dass
der ehemann habe der gemeinschaft sein
[Applaus]
mit den protestaktionen im
schauspielhaus und auf der straße
befinden sich die jugendlichen in der
schweiz in guter gesellschaft in
deutschland und frankreich verlangen
junge menschen nach sozialer
gerechtigkeit und persönlicher freiheit
sie stellen autoritäten in frage dafür
nehmen sie konfrontationen in kauf
politisch maxi international ist
gesellschaft sehr stark von patrick
prägt sie führt eine bipolare system usa
gegen sowjetunion das bedeutet dass
antikommunismus sehr stark verbreitet
ist das ist ein bitterer
konformitätsdruck dieser zeige was geht
oder wie immer politisch denkt also
reformen sind wir im 860 ein guter luft
gleiten in frankreich gelebt es große
massen zu mobilisieren
die ideale sind von männlichen
kommunistischen ikonen beeinflusst und
in deutschland schaut man sich um
studentenführer rudi dutschke
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also mit dass die züge generation 860
mythologisierung also mit curtis relativ
wenig negatives user von deiner wo
politisch tätig wechselt die g t au und
ethisches naheliegender aber insgesamt
eines gewitters muss sie sich der
verdacht als 60 passiert worden sind
weitere stärken die in frage stellt zb
die helden für die plakat mit dem motto
am ho chi minh
das wird relativ wenig reflektiert uns
nichts vor der 68er generation
das muss mit etwas abstand und wenn sich
die nutzer miteinander das heißt man
auch nur gedacht du sie gilt in der
startminute 2000
[Applaus]
ganz anders ausgesehen
viele studenten nervt der aktivismus
ihrer kollegen
[Musik]
in der schweiz sind es gar nicht so
viele die auf die straße gehen aber sie
sind ausdauernd laut und oft kreativ das
wiederum ist interessant für die medien
und entsprechend häufig wird berichtet
länder verbinden für die
demonstrierenden ist die lautmalerische
verklärung des vietnamesischen
revolutionärs in amerika vor allem
natürlich mit dem wehrdienstverweigerung
und so und die ganze antikapitalistische
kampagne mir nie die bewegung hätte wie
musiker hat das ist wirklich ein
wahnsinnig wichtiger moment also media
und insofern wichtige rolle spielt dass
sie wichtige multiplikatoren eigentlich
sind oder erst die globale ereignisse
kommen sagen wo wir kritisiert stube von
demütigungen ist über freuen sie sich
freuen oder zweiter weltkrieg oder die
täter im 40
[Musik]
in den usa betrauern die menschen ihre
opfer
der krieg in vietnam scheint mehr und
mehr sinnlos eine riesige
friedensbewegung und steht und sie
schwappt auf europa
auch in der schweiz gehen landesweit
menschen gegen den vietnamkrieg auf die
straße
ja das ist ja das was in dieser zeit
viele hofft also weiter südlich wird
nicht zu der ihre aktionär genau das
habe ich die bälle genau was ich mit dem
service
das ist schon grausam markiert sondern
grauenhafte kann ich bilder gesehen und
da bricht mir sehr und ich fühle mich
total hilflos gegenüber sind und denke
warum warum hat mobilisieren ich glaube
nicht dass ist craemer bin ich hier ich
hätte ganz fertig konnte aber sehr
individuell so verriet wo sich
verpflichten die einsätze wo defizite
und aufkirchen anregungen stütze ich
wäre schon so wie die arbeit der punkt
ist etwas mehr als problem haye ist das
natürlich kann man gar demonstrieren
natürlich machen wir das aber ganz
wichtig jetzt einfach nicht mehr drum
finger schauen sie mal hier will man
aber oft als head up display weckt und
ich glaube das ist die bewegung 1968
zielt auf althergebrachte strukturen in
der gesellschaft
denn materiell geht es aufwärts
[Musik]
wirtschaftliches der schweizer meister
schweizerinnen und schweizer sehr gut
ganz so gut wie noch nie und es sich um
ein vom monat geld vor ich bleibe wo man
ziemlich bleibt wenig freizeit
er steckt zum beispiel zum platter nicht
aufkommen radio auf also sagen dass ich
alles erst mal ich sie eigentlich und
hätte die generation wo um die zeit vom
zweiten weltkrieg geboren worden ist und
über den g 8 60 worden sind sehr stark
prägt und sehr stark unterschiedlicher
lebens weil dieser lebenserfahrung der
älteren die rolling stones kommen nach
zürich sie spielen eine musik die für
aufbruch und ungehorsam steht
[Musik]
grund sind die bad boys sie ja bei
borussia und ich muss sagen dass ein
can't get no satisfaction das ist
einfach daisy wo alles ausdrückt hat was
man sich damals auch stimmig so kraft
[Musik]
ich bin natürlich dann am konzept ja im
horr-stadion dem legendären konzert ja
und ich freue mich nur erinnern dass das
in praxis und ziehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
energie unglaubliche energie und
islamisten
wir müssen halt zuschnitt hat ja am reck
oder fotos cuba sí ja natürlich links
und eine sehr schlechte image gau damals
drogen unter heftiger blabla und so
weiter
das heißt dass ich natürlich für polizei
und völlig konzert sie das ist so starke
energie und sich dann folgerichtig so
meine kappe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein zweites konzert im folgenden jahr
lässt die 68er bewegung wirklich in der
schweiz ankommen
[Musik]
am sogenannten monsterkonzert tritt jimi
hendrix auf und elektrisiert wiederum
die massen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auch hier folgen auseinandersetzung
[Applaus]
wenige wochen darauf kommt es im juni 68
zu den globus krawallen am denen es
zwischen jugendlichen und polizisten
definitiv eskaliert
gebäude vom globus ist damals leer
standen bildet lobes und zögerlich und
es ist schon länger erforderlich im raum
standen des staates gegenüber des
jugendzentrum zu yamaha turner autonomes
jugend und dann ruft straße deswegen und
haben den globus setzt ja danke peter
bichsel ja will das ist eine große
demonstration sie wohl letztlich dazu
riesige kabul geführt hat zu denen
berühmte globus körper ja dass ich danke
dir extrem stehen auseinandersetzungen
zwischen der polizei der behörde und und
der autonomie
viele suchen auch weniger laut nach
neuen lebensformen kommunen sind das
wovor die eltern ihre kinder waren es
geht in jungen darum gesellschaftliche
normen aufzubrechen und neue formen des
zusammenlebens auszuprobieren
[Musik]
aus gesellschaftlicher bereich wäre ich
der den verdacht dass 60 und auch das
gerinne wirklich hochhausen politische
weniger orders auch dass ich ganz klar
keine politische revolution sie aber
gesellschaftliche revolution ist es sich
in deinem sinn der sache für sich
vereinbaren dass man sich sascha kröner
neue erlaube
denn so blieben wir nun rückgängig kite
für eine machen
auch paare suchen nach neuen
lebensmodellen fern der kleinfamilie
vorstandschaft gezwungen ich glaube dass
die dortige traditionell nach lee
familie frau sich mit eigentlich
achtkampf alt dass sie nur filme kreativ
und ran.de motivierte wolf nur geld und
die fälle in posen
also ich viel vorteil darin dass matt
mannschaftsrat absehbar nur lehren apple
das meta somit praktiziere zb zwei pci
vorstellen dass mir diese frage wie
14.000 die werbeform ist ein weiterer
vortrag sind drin dass dadurch dass mehr
mit anderen zusammen rad und dann könne
noch steigen wie ich jedes mobilität
frei müssen entscheide flügeln und
frauen einfach innerhalb verdacht 60 60
recht schnell man gemerkt dass sie
eigentlich in bezug auf sie selber nicht
viele eintritt dass er tatsächlich hat
der sehr radikale vorträge kohl radikale
politische vorträge sind weder
gesellschaft verein drei sie entweder
klassenkampf betriebe um frauen relativ
schnell gemerkt dass das im vordergrund
steht und sie gemerkt dass ihre rollen
aber wohin zurückdenkt wurde ich für
eine 860 man immer noch die gleiche
chance schrieb arbeitern sekretariats
jobs erledigen und dann gedeckt als ein
sie sich eigentlich auf sendung sein
einfluss ist vor der kasse kommt und
dich und die vereinbarung
wichtig auf was mir in erster linie wird
ist ein anderer besser stetig für die
frau immer mehr frauen reagieren auf
diesen missstand
er hat dies schätzt das als teilnahme
ria demos aber mehr natürliche platz kam
zwar ganz ohne im cs habe ich eine
schrieben oder gar nicht zu fragen zum
beispiel die einzige waffe danach gesagt
das fallen der frauenministerin und das
glas oder gehört ihm wird klar sie
müssen sich selber wären sie schließen
sich zu frauen befreiungsbewegung fbb
zusammen andré valentin ist eine von
ihnen wolle man den sie herr mit einigen
freundinnen die farbe felix bewege
gründet vor was wenn der trauerfeier
wir möchten versuchen frauen die frauen
zum bewusstsein bringen dass sie in
einer unterdrückten stehlik laden ganz
konkret wie stellen sie sich ihre aktion
eigentlich vor allem in seide zwischen
provokativen aktionen und aktionen womit
inhalt vilzing mit provokativen aktionen
darunter verstand ich zum beispiel in
aktion wo man nur ständig setzt eine
ausstellung über frau wo die 13
traditionelle vorstellungen von der frau
wieder vermittelt dass man die aktion
einfach macht durchgesetzt mit dem ziel
die umstellung schließe das hat der
schock wirkung auf die öffentlichkeit
ich glaube ich bin damals genau genau
aus und grieche grund dax standen mit
dem mikrofon wird der maler hat nur
unter anderen bedingungen aber es sich
um die sind um die gleiche fordere
gegangen
ich ahne dass frauen die gleiche
möglichkeit der hand gesellschaftlichen
möglichkeiten die man aber nicht
unbedingt dass sie jetzt meinen machen
sondern dass sie ihre spezifische alike
wirklich bringen sind und gehört werden
ich kann mich erinnern dass kurz nach
der gründung von der sbb nach dem
schauspielhaus aktion
ich habe mir sehr schnell postuliert
wandelt sogar im schauspiel salbe dass
mir immer schwer machen will um auch sie
vor der ex bringe
und das ist nicht nur um stimmungen
sondern allgemein um die situation vor
der frau in der schweiz wir
schweizerinnen hier auf dem bundesplatz
fordern das volle stimm und wahlrecht
auf eidgenössischer und kantonaler ebene
die gleichstellung der geschlechter ist
eine wichtige voraussetzung für die
verwirklichung der menschenrechte
vertraut mit
[Musik]
mannschaft jetzt ganz realistische logik
schülerzahlen radfahrer alle miteinander
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die jungen frauen entdecken das megaphon
und stören weitere anlässe zum
missfallen ihrer vorkämpferinnen für das
frauenstimmrecht
[Musik]
einerseits machen auf sich aufmerksam
machen dass ich quasi wieder positive
aspekt sie oder also sie schwer kann ich
das gar nicht die cdu so ein zentrales
gestürzt auf der anderen seite ein
sicher riskiert eben dass man sie dass
man schockiert ist dass man das ablehnt
dass man dann eben nicht nur aktionsform
ablehnt sondern auch fordern
dahinter steckt der marcello greift
wieder auf die mittel der 68er innen
zurück und scheut sich nicht regelmäßig
zu provozieren
letzter mit fünf user frau in alleiniger
weggezogen und herr bh verbrannt und
genauso erwartet eingestellt und genau
zu ihr seht ist zwar traurig was der
welt mit saic ist zwar geschichte augen
frei zu machen was der welt unsere super
individualisierte weilt und
einheimisches gemacht und zum aufzeigen
was mark passiert
das resultat ist sieht es das fördere
und kommentare dazu wird in einer plane
jeder tag wie tätig sieht mehrheit
vergewaltigung mord raub mit hey
wirklich ganz einfach sie darf mazda
setzt das hotel wieder gestattet ein
niedrigen der sache der frau schaden
realität ist junge frauen sollen sich
heute an solchen frauenbildern
orientieren so wird es in castingshows
und in den sozialen medien vermittelt
da muten die miss wahlen mit ihren
klischees von dünnen und braven frauen
geradezu harmlos an
[Applaus]
deswegen ist er so doch tradition und
geschichte die der schweiz mittlerweile
unser forums karriereleiter sind also
sagen hat viel schweizer freude andere
miss schweiz ist ein kräftiges schütze
nicht wenn das tier harmlos und schadet
ja jemand darum miss wahlen gibt es in
der schweiz seit den frühen 60er jahren
die fdp frauen reagieren 1968 kreativ
darauf für schönheitskonkurrenz das ist
ja furchtbar der weit über trauer wieder
illusion as roma verhältnis sind doch
county und versucht das so spranger also
ein bewusstseinsprozess in gang zu
bringen und dann bin ich gerne bereit
und hat ein tatsächlich wurden breite
dritte preis gemacht ich habe schon von
über die schönheitskonkurrenz und wie
das ist wie man sich wieder hervor und
und am schluss ist mit einem so spontan
der priester hatte sich vor dem dessert
wird versteigert öffentlich auf der
jeder weiß wie von select und das galt
gott und die baby pille automat von
behinderten
aus der baby pille sind ein sehr
wichtiger faktor ihre sexuelle
emanzipation von der frau dann so ist
sie unabhängig von ihrer biologische
konstitution kassierer ihres lagers
programmteile wie sie wohl nicht
sie ist auch nur eine konstitution
bundes ich sie muss nicht monogam sich
vom schlaf mit dem sich das ist
natürlich beträchtlich sie ich habe mich
erinnern ich bin zum frauenarzt und der
seit ich sage ich möchte unbedingt
bisher zum verhört wie ich das noch
mitmachen möchte ich mutter katherine da
momentan ja den druck strohmann um seite
ja da gibt es ein neues lied aller
verhütungspillen noch okay ich bin so
stolz dass ich schuld bin und die bälle
spielerschaft auf mich und alle frau als
inkorrekt gesagt dass ich spiele
das was hier zum verhört es hat sexuelle
revolution hat sicher steht kunden vor
allem in dem sinn dass frauen viel
selbstbestimmter eingriff der eigenen
körper und die eigene sexualität
bestimmen sind wie zutage dass frau
genau stehe auch experimentiert hat dass
man sich auf keine klare vorstellung
gelöst wie jetzt sechs muss das motto
eigene sachen ausprobiert hat der
gitarrist und ich bin ich darüber dass
ich sitze also von 68 auf ihn fiel in
ramersdorf als sie und dem senior ich
sicher 6 oder sexuelle beziehung mit so
anders dass spekulanten kolumbien ganz
wichtig man durch selber untersuchen
keine lernen genau und das ist ein ganz
wichtiger prozess ich bin von kopf
einmal im körper böcklin und herrn
anfangen im körper mehr respektieren und
den schwarzen hund aufpassen
ja das ist der hat dann benötige der
körper ist mit ampel sage kinder ja
[Musik]
und wenn schon
genommen da und wien an
[Musik]
viel spaß
also jetzt habe ich ja über sexualität
gesprochen was ist eigentlich mit ihrer
sexualität auf eure generation die sich
in der aktion ist wichtig so die erst
die internet porno generation
ja es ist nicht immer lustig muss ich
sagen und zwar wie es ist hat schon
krass was der alles mit graviert und was
es für vorstellungen beherrschen und ich
glaube es ist sehr sehr wichtig dass man
über das arbeit und der bedarf
diskutiert
[Musik]
der unter glaubst dass eure generation
sexuell sagt manfred risch als zum
beispiel mehr wachse mit dem motto wir
das 6 funktioniert war klar ist mega
penis orientiert und mega heftig das ist
damit mit dem maximum ist das mitgefühl
und die 50 jahre alt ist das noch nie
ich glaube dass ich glaube dass es geht
absolut und ich schlafe mit mancher
einfach nur mal zum sex ist jetzt die
möglichkeit hätten wir das ist absolut
kein problem
du hast möglichkeit irgendwann brach
steht mit 20 minuten takt in vier
stadtteilen 16 die möglichkeit gibt
frage stehen was haus lebt also das ist
ja wir das ist genau zu dem komitee wie
bei euch was mir sorge macht sie hier
bilder von sexualität und die bilder von
folie points und pflanzenwelt bedeutet
dass wir etwas machen
moni dass man eigentlich weiß dass ich
das eigentlich gern möchte das ging
offenbar auch anderen 68
[Musik]
in den wenigen wochen kommune die ich
erlebt habe hat er jeder sein zimmer an
stellte sich immer die frage wer schläft
bei jeder sollte mit jedem schlafen in
jedem sex haben
für mich war das nicht einfach aufs
exempel gemacht
das ist sehr häufig waren an bord gelöst
wir dürfen nie versucht ich sie jeder
schlaf mit jedem und es gibt kann zb
aber psychisch nicht berücksichtigt
wurde
wie eigentlich ab so funktionieren und
dass man nicht einfach per dekret sagen
jetzt immer noch nie versucht ich jetzt
geht's kamp sydney und dann funktioniert
und es hat viel liedern og identität vor
der freie sexualität und frauen sind
sich doch sehr oft missbraucht foto
missbraucht foto oder bewusst einmal
bucht mit dem starken mir frauen frauen
neckar wieder auferstand ihr leben sind
ja ich genau das war mir hört wieder
vorteile das ist generation
wahrscheinlich zwischen china und jeder
generation woods hat das buch - resultat
ist dass mir keiner frauennetzwerk im
land funktionieren meinung nach
solidarität oder künftig weniger frauen
solidarität und mehr fordert dass wieder
mehr frauen wieder vor ihm mit dass wir
den rückzieher zu machen
ich glaube es ist absolut richtig
die
studieren
die frauen befreiungsbewegung mietet den
siebzigerjahren räume zu denen
ausschließlich frauen zutritt haben
hier können sie sich im geschützten
rahmen austauschen und beraten lassen
etwa in sachen schwangerschaftsabbruch
abtreiben ist immer noch verboten
mein bauch gehört mir lautet die devise
leider nicht
ihre neuen lebensformen und
gesellschaftlichen errungenschaften
wollen die frauen auch gesetzlich
verankert haben
sie sind im besitz gehören mehrheit wird
und als politischer natur setze sondern
das sind sehr langlebige prozess sie
gott als fristenlösung sein terroir
brauer mutterschaftsentschädigung
immerhin im februar 1971 eine gute
nachricht frauenstimmrecht mit großer
mehrheit angenommen worden
einige monate später ziehen die ersten
frauen ins bundesparlament ein
1981 wird mit dem gleichstellungs
artikel die gleichberechtigung von frau
und mann in der schweizerischen
verfassung verankert die rechtliche
macht des mannes über seine frau soll
ein ende haben
darum ist ein neues eherecht geplant
widerstand kommt von rechts
wir glauben nicht dass das schweizer
volk dieses ehe und familienfeindliche
gesetz dass ehe und familie völlig
umkrempeln will annehmen wird noch immer
halt die alte melodie in vielen katzen
haben uns unsere eltern gelebt die frau
gehört an den häuslichen hielt der mann
ist der die frau ernährt die frau erhöht
an den häuslichen trotzdem tritt 1988
das neue eherecht in kraft allerdings
erst 20 jahre nachdem andré valentin
dies in ihrer rede im schauspielhaus
gefordert hatte ab jetzt sind frau und
mann vom gesetz her gleichberechtigt
ich danke sich viel passiert wenn ich
sehe was trauer junge frauen mit wasser
salz verständlichkeit sie bestimmt die
sachen wurden kürzlich oder so oder was
sie für berufslaufbahnen ich will da
kann ich nur träumen davon
ich bin schon glücklich sie dass ich
mich aus dem elternhaus und deren
schicksal frau war also dem mich gestand
an um in eigener weg gegangen bin
ihr weg führt sie über italien
deutschland und frankreich bis heute ins
tessin dem herkunftsort ihre mutter
immer lebt sie in kommunen oder alleine
nie in einer kleinfamilie
[Musik]
mini entschädigen
die habe ich nicht erzwungen über ein
intellektuell infektion sondern das
labor hat mir immer begegnungen
organisiert irgendwie aus dem bezirks
griff lacht will ich mit und im lack
stande bin um mich dem nicht verweigern
dann ist an den wagen stunde war nicht
zur klage hat das große lob ich alles
1972 wird sie ungeplant schwanger und
entscheidet sich für ihr kind vater ist
ein italienischer genosse aber sie zieht
ihren sohn mit einem anderen mann auf
nach ein paar jahren führt ihr
spiritueller weg alle drei für mehrere
jahre nach indien zu einem guru heute
lebt ihr erwachsener sohn mit frau und
kind in berlin
[Musik]
jetzt ist sie 74 großmutter und lebt
seit ein paar monaten in einer
hausgemeinschaft zusammen mit ehemaligen
weggefährten aus indien
ja genau ein leben in der unsicherheit
andrä und marco waren früher auch einmal
ein paar
wir waren mal zusammen es war intensiv
jetzt sind wir beste freunde
diese eifersucht und all das das war
natürlich in der zeit war nicht oben
ohne auch sehr aktiv waren in alle
richtungen wir haben das ausgelebt zwar
auch richtig zuständig die letzten jahre
hat andré alleine in frankreich gelebt
und es genossen das hat sich jetzt
geändert
irgendwann mal reicht mit dem alleinsein
ja und es gibt so viele menschen singles
alt oder jung die alleine sind da ist
einsamkeit ja und es gibt ja furchtbare
berichte wo die leute dann und tod sind
und niemand und so womöglich nicht enden
so wie sie ziehen sich viele aktive
kämpferinnen von 1968 wenn sie älter
werden auf den inneren oder spirituellen
weg zurück
in den 80er jahren schließen frauen
buchläden und andere frauen räume wieder
[Musik]
die fbb löst sich 1989 auf
1991 kam ein erneutes aufbaut
es kommt zum großen nationalen
frauenstreiktag zehn jahre nachdem
gleichstellungs artikel die
gleichberechtigung im alltag nicht
umgesetzt ist
dennoch viele halten die probleme sehr
gelöst gleichstellungsbüros werden in
frage gestellt
es ist so dass dem mann situation war ja
das büro verursacht hat wiegand
abgeschlossen
viele junge frauen sehen das heute
anders und nehmen den kampf gegen
ungleichheit und diskriminierung der
frauen wieder auf juso-präsident den von
cello hat feminismus groß auf ihre
fahnen geschrieben
die feministisch mir ganz amt und das
frau erlaubt
tamara von michelle und nimmt sich ihre
vorkämpferinnen von 1968 zum vorbild sie
mobilisiert und provoziert sowie mit
schmuck machten mit macht die finger
unbedingt genauso wenig das gern macht
zu sagen was es bleibt die revolution
erste tat dass ich mich spruch oder
hatte sie den jungen frauen und männer
dazu bringen den kampf gegen
diskriminierung gemeinsam aufzunehmen
[Musik]
mit welcher frechheit herausforderungen
stehe dass das hat man von mir dass ich
das ist wirklich dass ich ein frohes
glaube mit desto trotz wenig genauer
frage nach wie vor viel mehr gesendet
aus mini mancher kollege weder nach wie
vor für angers in szene gesetzt
diskutiert und somit auf einen kanzler
ab und auch die frau aber wir sagen
missbraucht wurde opfer von sexuellen
belästigungen das thema war heute
unglaublich 2016 rück die
diskriminierung wieder ins öffentliche
bewusstsein
der grund wer heute amtierende
amerikanische präsident äußert sich in
skandalöser abschätzig kite über frauen
weltweit gehen menschen auf die straße
auch in zürich mobilisieren sich wieder
mehrere tausend frauen und männer
das gab es seit den 90er jahren nicht
mehr
[Musik]
und ein jahr später ist es wieder eine
öffentlich machen von machtmissbrauch in
den usa die der bewegung schub verleiht
der filmproduzent harvey weinstein soll
schauspielerinnen belästigt haben auch
vergewaltigungs vorwürfe werden laut
dies tritt die miete bewegung in den
sozialen medien los unzählige frauen
machen sexuelle belästigung im alltag
öffentlich auch in der schweiz sind die
gläser und das heißt wie man
weitermachen
seit man hier herrschen die kraft
gebracht
juni passiert wird nicht passieren und
genau den feminismus heißt in meiner
schritt witziger ich glaube ein andere
wichtige frage
ich sehe ja das neue opfer vor dem
ganzen druck und ihrem rollenverhalten
und all dem was sie ihnen aufzwingen
wurden ist das solide trotzdem absolut
das heißt es ist wirklich eigentlich mal
um frau hat wirklich die sache
hinterfrage
es ist es auch vor bewusstseinswandel
ohne bewusstsein über etwas kann sich
nichts wandeln
[Musik]
damals wie heute ist die familie der ort
wo dieser wandel beginnen muss sobald
kinder kommen ist es mit der
gleichberechtigung oft vorbei so steht
beispielsweise schweizer männern bis
heute kein vaterschaftsurlaub zu und
männer reduzieren selten ihr
arbeitspensum nachdem sie fertig sind
trotz gleichstellungsgesetz verdienen
frauen bis heute weniger als männer
und in den geschäftsleitungen grosser
schweizer unternehmen sind gerade einmal
sieben prozent frau die 68er frauen
haben die gesellschaft verändert jetzt
gilt es sie gemeinsam mit den männern
weiter zu denken
[Musik]
und was muss strom vor 50 jahren
feministische bewegung aktiv ziel ist es
neue feministische bewegung mit
vervecken vom inneren erfahren divide
[Gelächter]
wirklich doof wenn du jedem app ist
wirklich spürt ausbau ja und du musst
das machen dann dank dafür und galt
trotz der hindernisse trotz der
schwierigkeit lass dich nur die heutige
und tipps
andere finden wo genau so danke wie du
mit denen du wo du dich von ihnen
verstanden und unterstützt wird und das
bildet das kraft wo wird er als
weiterbringen wird
genau
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
s